welcome back to glamour and filtered
host by meet josh smith
and today we're joined by my babe and
also to start lovecraft country
it's journey smaller
[Music]
we're gonna be serving some piping hot
tea today aren't we
because let's get real
the tea you have brewed in lovecraft
country
well what shout outs like it's gonna be
really nice like period drama
like loving it obviously going to be
gritty and you're like bam
monsters bam sci-fi bam
but like for you when you first got this
what were you what did you think
oh my gosh for one i was just so
excited when i got it and i'm such a fan
of sci-fi
and horror and thriller you know since i
was young i remember
seeing silence of the lambs i'm being
terrified when i was 10 years old
of hannibal lecter but loving it you
know
but felt most of my career that i was
just kind of shut out from the genre
because um so often we
are written as like you know the black
chick that's killed
in the first act as an artist it's just
not very satisfying
um to to play those roles and so
that's why for so many reasons i just
had to be a part of it
yeah i think it's so powerful what
you're saying about
the fact that there were so many doors
probably close to you before you got to
this place where you could play a role
like this what do you think have been
some of the most
triggering hurdles that have obviously
shaped you
along the way to get to this point in
your career
art is powerful representation matters
and where we are as an industry
for women of all kinds is abysmal you
know
but particularly for women black and
brown women women of color
me and my peers you know we all have
very similar
hurdles um just in having access to
equal opportunity
having access to rich stories to women
uh who are written in a way in which
you're not just a girlfriend
you're not just there to help push his
plot point out
you know to have characters in which
their
their living breathing flesh human
beings who have desires who are flawed
who have strengths but also weaknesses
who do very questionable things who
aren't always
the you know best person or
you know who have these different
dynamics these contradictions
it's so rare that you get access to
scripts that are written that way
um and i i think a lot of the problem
has to do with the fact that women of
color have been shut out so
much from the storytelling process
according to the annenberg
um institute something like over 1300
films from
2007 to 2019 you know
of the 1300 films only one percent were
directed by women of color
think about that one percent of all
women of color
mind you there's just a lot of work we
have to do but
i'm so encouraged because we're in a
point
in um in the industry where there are so
many amazing voices like amisha green
like a gina prince
would like an eva duvernay these really
powerful
storytellers who are reimagining
these genres and these stories and
centering black voices
and so it's a it's a very encouraging
time for me
because there are so many fierce
storytellers because i watched it just
after
um the first episode i watched it just
after george floyd was killed
and i remember thinking wow this is
really timely like
this is kind of stuff we need on our
screens right now but the thing is it's
like
it is timely but it's also it's overdue
like we needed this and it would have
been timely ten years ago five years ago
two years ago like
it's this whole discussion about this is
a timely piece
is actually kind of redundant because
we've needed this before
how seen have you felt
going through your career and like
because for instance like the question
is always
did you feel seen growing up right but
do you feel seen
as an adult woman i think if you
are black and female you know the
question
the answer to that unfortunately is no i
have battled this
erasure of the black female voice
in art my entire career you know um
but i do agree with what you're saying
you know lovecraft is so incredibly
timely but
when would it have not been timely you
know
if it was released so in any week of any
month of any years in 1619
the themes explored in our show would be
timely you know you know i think art is
so powerful i think art
has the power to to shift culture um
and i don't think you can see real
change affected on a policy level
um on a political level without first
shifting culture
and our siblings siblings of all kind
you know
we have to use our voice for them
because um if not now when you know
for me i was watching it i was thinking
about you know the
the cafe scene when you first go in in
the first episode and the racial
discrimination you face
on it on a daily level as that character
is so extreme but also the systematic
levels of it the levels of that
oppression are so extreme as well
for you what kind of everyday
racism do you still have to come up
against
you know my my family and i come from a
very big close family
but there were times in which we were
the only black family
in the neighborhood you know my mom my
mom being black my dad being jewish
they i remember our fish being put on
our lawn the morning of the million men
march
and i was a kid but that's something
that you know
forever will stay in your head i
remember our car being keyed with the
n-word
um i remember my mom being called it i
remember you know
can't soda cans being thrown at me and
my siblings when we were
out jogging you know these are things
that i memories that you put into
your art you know and approaching lenny
i went back and did a lot of research
and one thing you discover
is this this feeling that i felt growing
up of feeling displaced
is not new you know james baldwin talks
about
the the shock that you experience
as a black american this is your
birthplace and yet
this nation has not evolved a place for
you
um and how isolating that is how lonely
that is you know
and so as an artist when i when i take
on a project like lovecraft it's
incredibly
cathartic because i can pour these
memories into it
yeah and i think as well do you think
that
doing that and pouring that trauma that
you personally face in your ancestors
face and putting that onto the screen
takes on a new meaning now you're a
mother as well
absolutely i wasn't a mother when
trayvon martin was killed
but i do remember that the
feeling of connecting to sabrina
you know and and and the pain i felt
that as a mother she has to bury her
child
right you know um i know what it's like
to
witness uh a family member a brother
a friend put in the back of a police car
i know what it's like to be put in the
back of a police car for no reason
um and harass you know these are
things that i'm aware of and and so it's
not lost upon me that i am raising a
black son
in america and while i bust my ass
you know to be able to provide him a
life
to protect him you cannot buy yourself
out
of oppression you cannot buy yourself
out of racism it's just not possible you
will not be immune i work with
you know people on the front lines and
try to assist in the movement in any way
i can
because i'm feud as a as a black mom to
to not
to hope that we can change our world so
that my son doesn't have to experience
those things he should not have to you
know when my
white female counterparts you know she's
not gonna have to have the same talks
with her son that i will have to
the level of like racial exclusion but
also gender exclusion
you have to face like every day so it's
like this character has to face
not only a racial discrimination but
gender discrimination
the patriarchy benefits from white
supremacy and white supremacy
benefits from the patriarchy one cannot
exist without the other
the other being someone who lives at the
intersection of multiple identities
um yeah it is
it's atrocious you know um as black
women we're we're the spine of this
nation okay like we're the backbone of
this nation this nation was built upon
our backs
um we birthed it okay and so i take such
pride
in in the queens that i stand upon
you know i come from royalty and my
grandmother
raised four children as a single mom she
was the first black miss galveston
beautiful woman and went to work every
single day
to clean the homes of white folks and
she would do her hair
and she would press out her her her
dress
and the dignity that she had
in approaching her work in spite of the
fact that they mistreated her they
underpaid her then
they neglected her and abused her it's
something that's always
stuck with me is that there is power in
that it
is so radical to just not allow society
to rob you of your dignity to say i am
not of lesser value just because you
can't see my worth
it's so powerful yeah and i think as
well it must been so incredible to be on
this set
have this incredible group of people
around you
because i mean you go through it
you're not like you put everything on
that screen
and more mentally physically from going
on this adventure
what do you think you've learned about
yourself
you know i've i've learned i learned a
lot about myself i learned
a deeper level of resilience um
this project required so much of me it
cost me a lot
um but you know
it was necessary it's very cathartic you
know there was a lot of pain that i was
able to pour into this
you know sometimes you set these limits
on yourself of like
ugh i could never do that or i could
never get past that
and then you do and life goes on i'm
still here
i survived you are honey we as women
also we put such
pressure on ourselves to do it all and
be it all
and i did also learn that you know about
myself just the
levels of pressure i was putting myself
on like i was still nursing hunter
through the
entire season of lovecraft um
i know you know it's just like
i had this real expectation of myself
of you know uh what it meant to be
a working mom what it meant to be an
artist
and and i think i've learned through
this process
that i had to ease up a little bit on
um these standards i had set especially
in in my motherhood you know that some
of it was a little
unrealistic and i was killing myself
you know trying to do it all instead of
having grace upon myself
and and being kind to myself and i
realized that
trying to kill myself was going to serve
no one you know
make me a better mom it didn't you know
i was suffering from mom guilt
throughout the entire process of like oh
my gosh i got i'm nursing him but i
gotta go and i gotta go do
this scene and i've been gone for hours
and it doesn't service you in any way
no no you've gotta be your own ally and
warrior in any given situation right
yeah and i was honestly being my worst
critic
of course if you could sit the you down
who is on this scene call and she was
just about to go out
into her career to pursue acting what
would you want to say to her what kind
of advice would you want to give the
younger you
don't ask for permission own your power
and be kind to yourself yes
that is the teacher
[Music]